Speaker 1: OK.
This is a I don't want to spend a lot of time
on this.
This relates to the bridge collapse in Pittsburgh
now at the top of the show.
We already talked about the hundreds of bridges
just in New Jersey that have the same poor
rating as does, as did the bridge in Pittsburgh
that collapsed.
But I want to show you just like at the bottom
of the barrel right wing opportunism on this
in a segment on Fox News about the bridge
collapse, FOX host or anchor or whatever,
Julie Banderas said this is.
What happens when Joe Biden talks and talks
about an infrastructure bill and doesn't get
anything done?
Now, of course, Joe Biden passed the infrastructure
bill, but Julie Banderas apparently didn't
know that.
Notice also that everybody on screen is just
kind of nodding along.
You've got Kayleigh McEnany.
You've got arbiter of ideas, Dave Rubin and
others.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Very tails.
I love fairy tales.
I mean, but normally I only enjoy them when
it's during a bedtime story in the evening,
not on a daily basis.
For the past year since, the White House has
been overrun by Democrats, but President Biden
has been making promises over promises, over
promises, and as you've noticed, none of them
have come true.
And when a president makes promises and then
doesn't deliver.
And then something like this where a bus,
I mean, there could have been multiple casualties.
So thank God, nobody was killed.
But honestly, a bridge collapsing right before
he's back in June of twenty twenty one.
He started talking about his bipartisan infrastructure
deal, something bipartisan about it.
If if it was bipartisan, it would have been
passed by now.
So clearly, he's not getting the message across
to the other side of the aisle, which by the
way, if you remember during his campaign,
he said that he was going to be the president
that was going to reach across the aisle,
that he was actually going to make policy.
Speaker 1: And you see Kayleigh McEnany there
nodding along now.
That infrastructure bill did pass the bill
passed months ago, it passed in November and
it was bipartisan and that 19 Republican senators
and 13 Republican representatives voted for
the bill later.
Julie Banderas quote tweeted That quote tweeted
that she misspoke.
Now she's since deleted the tweet because
the tweet is so stupid.
But her explanation was quote I misspoke.
I was referring to the president touting the
bipartisan bill back in June.
And here we are today.
And nothing has improved.
Hence the bridge collapsed.
Now it was so stupid because it takes a while
to actually get that money and get contracts
and distribute it.
Her criticism was about Joe Biden and the
passage of the bill.
Now she's saying the criticism is actually
that that bridge wasn't yet fixed.
But Biden, obviously is no more to blame for
that than the fact that Trump had four years
to do infrastructure and didn't.
The bridge problems are major problems.
The infrastructure problems are a disaster.
I've been talking about it on the show for
a decade.
There's no question about that.
But the initial claim and the criticism and
then the explanation, it's all completely
bogus, like this is really the worst of trash
politics.
She makes a statement bait bait based on completely.
They're not wrong facts.
It's based on lies.
She takes the statement back, but says my
general analysis was still good and it's considered
a correction.
But it's so stupid that then she deletes it
like this is really the worst of the worst
of the worst.
And unfortunately, you know, you've got these
bobbleheads on Fox News, their heads on a
swivel nodding along.
Even Kayleigh McEnany, who has to know, has
to know that the bill had already passed.
Then it passed months ago and it passed with
Republican support as well.
This is another one of those examples where
you quite literally will have brain rot if
you just listen to the analysis they put out.
And you believe it?
Yeah, Joe.
Joe Biden is to blame because he never passed
that bill.
Well, he did pass it.
He did pass it.
And it takes some time to get things done.
But what about the four years Trump had during
which he said he was going to do infrastructure
and he didn't?
Well, this is where we end up.